We're going to pick up
where we left off on Monday.
And where we left off was
we were dissolving stuff.
We talked about how
things dissolve.
Why does something
dissolve maybe
in this solvent versus that?
And how does it dissolve?
And what makes them--
and then we say, well,
what if we had something
and we wanted it to dissolve
all the way until it
couldn't dissolve anymore?
Well, that's called
saturation, right?
And we talked about that.
We talked about how if you
had a general reaction, maybe
we had something
like this, aA plus bB
goes to and comes
back from
cC plus dD,
then this reaction
can happen in both ways, right?
And so the general concept that
we called a reaction quotient,
reaction Q, is equal to--
remember, it's equal
to the concentrations
raised to those
stoichiometric coefficients.
And it's the products
over the reactants.
OK, so that's what we--
now then, we say,
well OK, that's
a thing that has
to do with maybe--
where's that reaction going?
What's dominating it?
And remember, these are the
stoichiometric coefficients,
and they're related to
literally the probability
that that reaction can happen.
OK, and so if you
want an intuitive
reason for the exponents, you
can think about this as, well,
if these all have to get
close enough in a given volume
to react, then that's where
those exponents come from.
But unlike the rate law--
and I said this Monday, and
I'm saying it again today--
they are not things that
are experimentally measured.
Instead, they just come from
the reaction itself, OK?
So we're just getting back
into the right mood here.
But then we said,
well, but look.
OK, this thing is reacting.
It's going back and
forth, whatever.
But what about once it
reaches equilibrium,
all right, equilibrium?
And when it reaches equilibrium,
it's the same thing,
but we call it Keq,
in equilibrium,
eq'm, equilibrium, right?
So that reaction quotient
has a very specific value,
a constant, a constant,
once this way is happening
in the same amount as that way.
Right, that's the
saturation point.
Well, if you're
dissolving something,
that's the saturation point.
OK, so it's where the
precipitation-- remember,
we wrote this as dissolution
and precipitation
when we were putting
stuff in solution.
And that's where we got to.
And we went a
little bit further,
and we had a specific example.
And that's where I
want to start today,
and that's silver chloride.
OK, so here we go.
So we have silver chloride.
And if I write this all out for
silver chloride, I've got AgCl.
And I've got a
little pinch of it,
like a little speck
of silver chloride.
And I'm putting
it into a beaker.
So it starts out as a solid,
and I add some water to it.
And the water is l,
because it's everywhere.
It's the liquid.
It's the solvent.
OK, it's the liquid that
I'm dissolving it in.
And we say, well OK, that's
going to go like this.
So that reaction, it's going
to give us silver ions--
remember salts, we did salts--
and chlorine ions, and
back to some more water.
OK, that's H2O.
Now, the aq means aqueous.
Because it's a
salt, right, these
are now dissolved ions,
because it's a salt.
So we write them like that.
And we know we got
water everywhere.
So oftentimes, we
leave the water out.
Oftentimes we don't
really write the water,
because it's on both sides.
And anyway, the water is
just surrounding stuff.
It's not necessarily
being consumed.
The concentration of the
water isn't changing.
The water is the water
in the liquid phase.
Well, OK, then we went
even further and said,
well, if you write
a Keq for this, then
that would look something like
the concentration of silver
plus in solution times the
concentration of chlorine
minus in solution.
And that would be divided
by the concentration
of silver chloride as a solid.
And then we said--
but hold on.
But hold on.
In the solid phase,
the concentration
isn't changing, right?
As a solid, the concentration
of silver chloride
is silver chloride.
It's a constant.
And so then we said, well
OK, if this is a constant,
this is a constant.
Then we can also absorb it
into the equilibrium constant.
And I somewhat
confusingly wrote it
as Ksp in both this
form and the form
that we know and
love for Ksp, which
is simply literally the
solubilities of these times
each other.
Right, and that is Ksp.
So I wanted just
to clarify this,
because a student asked a
very good question, which is,
which is it?
Is this in Ksp or
is this in Keq?
Well, the big full picture for
Keq, you'd write it all in.
But the solubility product is
focusing in on the dissolution
of these ions.
And so you wrap this into
the equilibrium constant,
because it's another constant.
So that's the
solubility product.
And that's where we
got to on Monday.
The solubility product is a
special equilibrium constant,
where what we're
talking about is--
what are the
concentrations when you've
reached saturation of this
dissolution precipitation
reaction, OK?
That's the solubility product.
That's Ksp.
So you wrap this
in, and you get Ksp.
You can think about
it as, well, maybe
you could have called this
some Ksp in a pre-Ksp.
And then you wrap
this in, and then it's
still just [INAUDIBLE],, because
it's still just a constant
representing this reaction.
OK, I just wanted to
make this super clear,
because this part leads
to confusion often,
that this gets left out,
because it's constant.
It doesn't change.
OK, good.
Now we get to that,
because this is a constant.
OK, so what does that mean?
Well, it means that if I
dissolve this thing in water,
then the equilibrium, the
equilibrium is a fixed number.
This equilibrium
product is fixed.
And that has a very
important meaning.
It's the green curve.
You see, it says equilibrium.
And so what that means is that
if I'm at point B, well, there
I go.
I've got my-- we said Ksp.
Ksp for this one equals,
what was it, 1.7 times 10
to the minus 10th.
Units are coming.
And so that's the Ksp for
silver chloride and H20.
Oh, and you have to say
at some temperature.
It will depend on temperature.
You often will just be at room
temperature, 25C, for example.
So often these get quoted
just at room temperature.
OK, so once I know that, then
I know that that's equilibrium
no matter what, right?
And so that means that if--
and then we solve this.
You said, well OK, if I
dissolve silver chloride,
and I had nothing
else, then the Ksp
would equal the
concentration of silver
times the concentration
of chlorine ions.
But those are equal.
And so we let each
one of them be x,
then it's equal to x squared.
And so we know that the
concentration of each of them
is 10 to the minus--
let me write it exactly--
1.3 times 10 to the minus fifth.
Now, it's a
concentration, so you
know that it's got to be
capital M, moles per liter.
And since that's the
case, since that's
where you know what it is,
then now you can back up.
Because this is the
concentration of Ag ions
and it's also the
concentration of chlorine ions,
then you know that
the units of Ksp
must be M squared, all right?
Units in this case,
moles per liter squared.
Must be, because otherwise
the concentration isn't right,
the units of concentration.
OK, now we're going
to play with this.
OK, so I'm at B. I'm at
point B. You see that?
There I am.
And I've got my
concentration of chlorine,
concentration of silver.
And I'm here.
And so that's 1.3 times
10 to the minus fifth.
OK, now if I didn't
have as much,
if I weren't at the saturation
point, then I could add more.
I'd be here.
And I could add more
solid silver chloride.
And eventually, I'd
reach this equilibrium.
But if I added more
than that, so now I'm
adding way more than I can, then
it's just going to be a solid.
And that's kind of boring.
So now I'm up here.
But maybe I add ions in.
So these are the ions.
So maybe I add a
whole bunch of ions.
Well, they're just
going to precipitate.
I can't be here and
be in equilibrium.
That's the point
of the green curve.
This K doesn't change.
This K is this K. That's
what the green curve is.
It is that being constant.
That's very important.
That is equilibrium.
Now, there is a way though
to move around on it,
because if I did, imagine now--
look at point C.
Imagine now that I've
found some source
of chlorine ions
and I add a whole bunch of them,
right, a whole bunch of them
into the solution.
I don't want to add silver
and chlorine together.
I just add chlorine.
Well, you can see
what's going to happen.
I have to get to equilibrium.
And so in order to stay in
equilibrium for silver chloride
in solution, then I must lower
my concentration of silver,
because I added
all this chlorine.
The only way to do
that is to eat up
some silver and precipitate.
That's the only way to do that.
And that has a name.
And that's what I want
to talk about next.
That is called the
common ion effect.
Now, this is an example.
This is an example of
a broader principle
which I mentioned Monday, which
is Le Chatelier's principle.
OK.
And that is that position
of equilibrium will move.
It's still equilibrium, but
it's moving on that green curve
to counteract change.
This is a very
general principle.
It applies to many, many
things, not just concentrations.
It applies to changes in
pressure and other changes
that you make in a system.
Here we care about
concentration.
And in this
particular case, we're
going to see it for
what happens when
you add ions of one particular
type and not the other.
That's the common ion effect,
but it's a very general effect,
that it resists the change.
Now, let's see how that works.
If I want a source
of ions, let's say
I want a source of
chlorine, one way
would be to add a whole
bunch of sodium chloride.
So let's suppose that I have--
OK, so as an example, I'm going
to add to this nice equilibrium
that I reached here--
so I'm at point B, OK?
And I'm going to add 0.1 moles
per liter of sodium chloride.
And this nearly-- and so
we're going to say it does--
it nearly fully disassociates.
And we'll be talking
about that later today.
And so that means that NaCl
basically goes to Na+ plus Cl-,
both in solution.
So if I put 0.1 moles per
liter of sodium chloride
into this container of
the silver chloride,
I'm basically going
to get 0.1, because
of the stoichiometric
coefficient
here, 1, 1, 1, right?
So if I put 0.1 moles
per liter of this,
I'm going to have 0.1 moles
per liter of chlorine ions
that I just dumped
into the container.
But the sodium is not
going to do anything.
But look at the chlorine.
That's going to mess
with my equilibrium.
But K is a constant.
So let's see what happens.
We can do it visually.
But we can also do it back when
we use the ICE table, right?
So now we're going to
go ICE again, AgCl.
And here's Ag+.
And here's Cl-.
So now I've added the--
OK, so my initial is
that this is solid.
And remember, this is the solid
that I'm putting in there.
And then my initial
is that I started
in that nice
equilibrium at point B.
So I've got 1.3 times
10 to the minus fifth.
And over here,
I've got the same.
But now the change,
now the change.
OK, so we're going to add
some chlorine ions, 0.1.
So I've added 0.1 moles
per liter of chlorine ions
from the salt, from
sodium chloride.
Yeah, but now some of
that is going to react,
because I just said, Le
Chatelier's principle
tells me that now it's
got to counter that.
And you can see
it right here too.
I'm adding a whole
bunch of chlorine.
Look at how far I'm going out.
0.1, that's literally
all the way out to here.
And so the amount of
silver has got to go down.
And what's going
to happen is it's
going to consume some of the
silver and form precipitate
to counter all this addition.
It's going to run the
reaction the other way.
So it's going to lose a
little bit there from the 0.1.
That's going to react
with the silver ions.
So that's going to also lose,
and this is going to gain.
That's how much
that's going to gain.
So those are the
variables, right?
This is the ICE table.
That's how much
it's going to lo--
these are going to react to
give me some precipitate.
And so the equilibrium
is more solid forms.
That's not a good
E. More solid forms.
And over here, it's 1.3 times
10 to the minus fifth minus x.
And over here, it's 0.1 minus x.
That's the
equilibrium condition.
I've added in a common ion.
This is the common ion effect.
Yeah, so now if you do the
math, then what happens?
Well again, Ksp is the same.
It's the equilibrium constant.
So it's the constant.
So that is going to
be the same value.
It's going to be 1.7 times
10 to the minus 10th.
But you see, Ksp is also
equal to the concentration
in equilibrium of the silver
ions times the concentration
of the chlorine ions.
So it's going to be 0.1
minus x times 1.3 times 10
to the fifth minus x.
And then we don't like doing all
this math, and so we simplify.
Then we can simplify,
because look,
you started with silver ions
in a very small concentration.
You can't take away
something you don't have.
And so x has got to be
somehow this or less, right?
And so x is a small number.
And this is a really big
number in comparison.
And so we like simplifying
our lives, right?
And so we like saying
that that's like 0.1.
We know that.
That'll make the
math a lot easier.
It'll make the math easier.
And so now we can say that this
is equal to 0.1 times 1.3 times
10 to the minus fifth minus x.
And then we get that
x equals 1.7 times 10
to the minus ninth.
That is the common ion effect.
What I've done, I've taken
this thing in equilibrium,
and I've added one of the ions.
And it changes the solubility.
Remember, the solubility
is what we care about.
That's what the solubility
constant helps us determine.
And I've literally just changed
it by orders of magnitude,
because now the
amount that this--
so this thing
precipitates like crazy.
I added in a little bit
of some other salt that
had chlorine ions.
And all of a sudden, silver
chloride precipitates out.
So here's a video of this.
This is kind of cool.
So watch.
This is an
equilibrium container.
And what I'm adding is
salt. And look at that.
What is that?
That's silver chloride
precipitate, right,
because the thing has
to reach equilibrium.
And so in order to
do so, what you do
is you suppress the solubility.
Literally, by adding chlorine,
the common ion effect,
you suppress the solubility
of the silver chloride.
It's pretty cool stuff.
That is the common ion effect.
Now, why does this matter?
Let me give you one--
no, I'll get to why
this matters in a second.
One more question.
Now without even doing the
math, check this one out.
This is cool.
Without even doing the math,
I can take barium sulfate,
and from the common ion
effect-- so barium sulfate is
going to go.
So what does that one look like?
Well, it's going to go to Ba 2+
plus SO4 2-, both in solution,
in solution.
Dissolved ions, this is a solid.
Now, here's the question.
Which of the following will be
required in the least amount
to dissolve the same
amount of BaSO4?
I don't need any
constants or math.
I can use this same principle,
because if I had some 0.1
molar or 0.01 moles per
liter of either of these,
what are they doing?
They're serving up ions, right?
In the one case,
you're serving up--
so in case A, you're
going to give me--
what do I have there?
H2SO4, so let's do A first.
H2SO4 is going to give me a
whole bunch of H+ but also SO4
2-.
And in case B, you have BaCl--
OK, so you have BaCl2.
And if I put that in, I've
got this in water, right?
But if this dissolves
in water a little bit,
then it's going to serve
up some Ba 2+ plus 2Cl-.
Either way, now you know
what's going to happen,
because if I'm trying
to dissolve something
and I add any of the
ions that it's dissolving
into from some
external source, it's
going to drive it this way.
It's going to precipitate.
So the answer has
to be just water.
Stick with pure
water in this case.
Otherwise you're going to
have more trouble dissolving,
just like we just showed.
You're going to have more
trouble dissolving, not less.
That's the common ion effect.
OK, so now why does this matter?
Why does this matter?
We go back to the pteropod.
And by the way, I
didn't have this link,
and I should have when
I showed you the--
and this is your
goody bag, et cetera.
There's some really
nice articles
here that you can find
related to these experiments
and other things about
ocean acidity in case
you're interested.
But see, what I did
was that this was my
why this matters on Monday.
And I wanted to tell you
about the goody bag and about
how things dissolve, because
Monday was about dissolving
and finding a saturation point.
Now we can get to the
next place, which is,
why does that matter for
the pteropod's shell?
What is the chemistry
that matters there?
OK, so I made the ocean
a little more acidic.
Why does that matter?
But you see, now we're
armed with the knowledge we
need to answer that question.
Now we're armed with it.
All we need to do, as always
with everything in life,
is look at the chemistry.
That's it.
Say that at the
Thanksgiving table.
You'll be very popular.
We said CO2 plus H2O.
This goes-- oh, find some
equilibrium to H2CO3.
Now, this is called
carbonic acid.
This is called carbonic acid.
There's the pteropod up there.
And there's the reaction
that's really relevant
that you'll see from the ones
we're about to write down.
Why?
Because the thing is that,
what happens to carbonic acid?
Well, carbonic acid also goes
through a dissolution reaction.
So this is CO2
dissolving in water.
So carbonic acid goes like this.
OK, it goes into HCO3- plus H+.
Now, here's the thing.
OK, what is the shell made of?
Well, the shell that's
dissolving, the core material
is calcium carbonate.
So that's CaCO3.
That's the shell.
And the shell also has
an equilibrium reaction
that happens.
The shell of a sea creature
is in dynamic equilibrium
with the ocean.
And so it's going like this.
It's going to, well,
OK, Ca2+ and CO3 2-.
OK, but the thing is, it
has an equilibrium constant.
All these have
equilibrium constants.
So for example, for
this one, the Ksp,
the solubility
product constant--
because this is a solid.
This is the solid
shell, solid, going
to ions in aqueous solution.
So the Ksp for that is
somewhere around 5 times 10
to the minus ninth, 5 times
10 to the minus ninth.
Yeah, but here's the thing.
We just went through this.
If I consume one of these or
change the concentration of one
of these and not the other--
we just did this.
If I could change
the concentration,
if I consume any of these, then
I might drive the reaction--
consume or produce.
If I change any of
these independently,
I'm going to drive the
reaction, because that's
how we keep to our K.
That's what Le Chatelier's
principle tells us.
And so what ends up happening
is you've got the extra H+ ions.
So these are ions in solution.
Where did they come from?
They came from the CO2
giving us carbonic acid,
which then gave us H+.
Those are what
I'm talking about.
Well, they react
with the CO3 2-.
This lowers the CO3 2-
concentration near the shell--
[STUDENT SNEEZES]
--right?
Gesundheit.
And if I lower this, because
I've taken some of this now
and I've reacted it, so
now I've got less of it.
And because of what we just
saw, if I've got less of this,
you're going to drive
this way, which is going
to dissolve more of the shell.
That's why this works.
Well, that's why this happens.
Works sounds like
a positive thing.
So this lowers the
concentration of CO3 2-,
and that drives
more dissolution.
That is what's happening.
And we now can understand
it in terms of the concepts
that we've just learned.
Historically, I mentioned
50 million years.
Actually, by some
accounts, it's 300 million.
It depends on which
studies you read.
But for at least 50 and maybe
as much as 300 million years,
the ocean has had a pH of 8.18.
Now, where's the-- oh.
So let's just say last, oh,
50 to 300 millionish years,
the ocean pH was 8.18.
And today, it's 8.07.
And the prediction is that
in 2100, it will be 7.8.
Now, as we will see
in a little bit--
and you say, what's pH?
And many of you
probably already know,
but I will tell you what
it is in a little bit.
But because this is
a logarithmic thing,
this is a lot, right?
Today the ocean
is 25% more acidic
than it's been in
300 millionish years.
And in 2100, it will
be 126% more acidic.
That's why they use 7.8 in the
experiments of the pteropods.
OK, right.
Why does this happen?
Why is this molecule an acid?
We're talking about
acidification of oceans.
Why is this an acid
in the first place?
What does it mean to be an acid?
And that is the next topic.
That is what I want
to talk about next.
What is an acid?
And an acid is something
that is very specific.
It has a very definite
meaning to it.
And I want to talk
about that today,
and then we'll continue
after the break.
So this molecule,
carbonic acid, is called
an acid because of that proton.
And you could feel it.
You could feel it
in this whole thing.
The proton is the thing that
caused the problem, right?
An acid, this is an acid
because of the proton.
So an acid, it's a dissolution
reaction, dissolution.
It's what we've
been talking about.
It's a dissolution
reaction that gives an H+.
Now if I think about it as a
generic case, generic acid A,
then the reaction looks
something like this.
I'm going to call out
the acid and the proton
that it gives separately.
OK, so this is HA.
So we do this because it
highlights that it's an acid,
H+ in solution--
and these can all be in
solution-- plus A- in solution.
All right, H+, A-.
Right, so I've
taken a proton off.
You see it's right there.
That's HA, HA, where A is
HCO3 and H is H. And then
what I've done is
I've transferred
the proton into solution.
That's an acid.
Now the thing is, you will
see a lot of places and people
writing H+.
And we will do that too, because
so many textbooks use H+.
But what I want you to know
is that H+ is never a thing.
We just write it that way.
H+ is not stable in water.
So the proper-- ah!
The proper way to write this
general reaction would be HA
plus H2O is going to go to--
and now I'm going to write
the full, so the
full goes both ways--
is going to go to H3O+ plus A-.
[STUDENT SNEEZES]
Gesundheit.
This is what happens, because
H+ is not stable in water.
But you will see H+
written all over the place.
When you see H+, and if it's
in water, know that it's H3O+.
That is what is stable.
OK, H+ in water is not.
Now, there's
something here that's
important in terms
of terminology.
And that is that these are--
notice that these are related.
The HA and the A-
seem very related.
And the H2O and the
H3O+ seem very related.
Well, they are, because a
proton is the only difference
between them.
And so those are
called conjugate pairs.
Conjugate, related,
conjugate pairs.
OK, those are called
Now, back in the day, there
was a lot of interest.
People knew about these kind
of liquids, mostly liquids,
for a long time.
And there was a lot of
experimentation before this.
Let's see, well, there's these
general classes of materials.
We're going to call
them A and B. Well,
A seems to always
taste kind of sour.
B is bitter.
A reacts with
carbonates to make CO2.
B reacts with fats and
soap to make soaps.
One reacts with metals.
The other doesn't.
And by the way, if
we mix them together,
we seem to always
get salt and water.
This had been going on for
centuries, this investigation
into properties of
acids and bases.
But who was it that came along?
Who was it that came along?
Svante!
Is there anything
you can't do, Svante?
I ask you again.
In the late 1800s, it was
Svante to the rescue who
first proposed that
what is happening here
is a dissolution reaction.
That is what an
acid or a base is.
It is that on the one
hand, you're given an H+,
which is what I just said.
But on the other hand, for
a base you're given a OH-.
And it was Svante
Arrhenius who first
put that down and first
conceived of acids and ba--
are we snapping?
Are we quiet
snapping for Svante?
I love it.
I've just recently
learned what that
means, which makes me happy.
Quiet snapping.
It's instead of clapping.
But you don't make noise, but
you still want to give props.
I got it.
I'm there.
I'm right there.
Now, OK.
OK, now here's the thing.
So we'll talk about it.
So Arrhenius says bases give
OH ions in solution, and oh,
acids give H+.
But we know that that's H3O+.
OK, we know that.
Yeah, but the thing is
there's disillusion reactions.
These things lead to really
small concentrations.
And so Soren Sorensen.
That is a beer bottle.
By the way, his research was
funded by a beer company,
and it was all about
the taste of beer.
He called it
looking at proteins,
but it was about beer.
And what he realized,
he said, I've
been doing all these
dissolution reactions of ions.
I think Arrhenius was right.
Ions are really
important, and we're
trying to measure these things.
But I'm sick of all these zeros.
I don't like writing 0.0001
or whatever all the time.
And oh, look at that, 1.3
times 10 to the minus fifth.
That's not efficient.
And so what Sorensen
did is he talked
about how you've got the power.
Now, what do I mean by power?
So many things, right?
But if I look at H+,
OK, H3O+, and I say it--
let's suppose the concentration
is 0.00, oh boy, 00001,
that's 10 to the minus 7.
But Sorensen wasn't
happy with that.
You simplified it.
Wait, two, four-- no, it's not.
OK, maybe it is now.
He said, well, 10
to the minus seventh
is still four characters
I got to write, four.
So he went to the math
department at his place
and he said, what else can be--
I want to talk about
the power of these ions.
And they're like, power,
well, that's the logarithm.
And so if you take the
log, it's the power
of hydrogen. Power of
hydrogen is the pH.
And that's simply minus the log.
They didn't want
negative numbers either.
Oh, but you can
have negative pH.
You can.
Why?
Because this is the
definition of pH.
Or you could do pOH, if
you're going with Arrhenius.
So the power of
hydrogen is the pH.
The pOH would be minus log
of the concentration of OH-.
That's the pOH.
But pH is the one
that we most often
see to describe whether
something is acidic or basic.
And so now you see, well,
OK, well, this is a pH.
Now this is easy, right?
It's a pH of 7.
And if the concentration were
0.1, it would be a pH of 1,
minus log, the
power of hydrogen,
the log, literally the log.
OK, now if you look
at scales of pH,
and it's a really
fun thing to do, then
what you find is that usually,
almost always actually,
you'll see the scale
ranging from 0 to 14.
That's what Sorensen
originally decided.
I'm going to talk about
these ions in solution.
I don't want to write
it out every time.
I'm just going to
have a simple scale.
We'll take the minus
log, and there you go.
Yeah, but you can see that
if the concentration is
more than one here, then
you could have negative pHs.
There's nothing special
about zero here.
It just so happens
that most things,
certainly that he was
playing with at the time,
were in this scale.
And here is a few
things that we know.
There it is, right?
OK, don't play with
that one, but play
with lemon juice, vinegar.
By the way, vinegar--
OK, wine is around 3 and 1/2.
Vinegar is around 2.
The word vinegar is
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
It's eager wine.
That's it, right?
But it's because of the
acidity, the acidity.
Well, it's more than that.
But it's the acidity is changing
by orders of magnitude, power.
And then you can go back and
you see, but OK, there's coffee.
I like that a lot.
And blood.
By the way, by the way,
talk about ocean acidity,
blood has a very
narrow range of pH.
And if you change the pH of
your blood by more than 0.2,
it is very likely
to lead to death.
So just think about that.
That's what we're
doing to the ocean.
OK, anyway, that was an aside.
Seawater, oh, pH 8.07
currently and dropping.
OK, baking soda, ammonia.
So this is very powerful,
no pun intended actually.
Now, these are
dissociation reactions.
These are dissolution reactions.
I'm taking an acid, and I'm
dissociating it in water.
And so you have the equilibrium
constant for that dissociation,
right?
And so if you go
back to that, that's
still going to matter here.
And that's going to be
important in thinking
about what an acid is.
Because, again, why is this it?
Well, because there's
these protons.
Well, how many of
them are there?
It depends on how it dissolved.
Where did it find
its equilibrium?
And so for some of
them, like I just wrote,
we just talked
about HCl plus H2O.
That went to H3O+ plus Cl-.
OK, now the thing is, if I had
0.1 moles per liter of HCl,
then it's going to lead to a
concentration of H3O+ of around
0.1 moles per liter,
because it's nearly full,
nearly full dissociation.
What do I mean by that?
Well, I mean that--
yeah, OK, so you'll often
see for an acid like
that, one arrow.
Well, we know that in reality,
there's another arrow there.
But see, here the acid
dissociation constant is huge.
So now we have a thing
for the equilibrium
of an acid, which
forms by dissociating
the acid into its ions.
And this is-- well, in this
case, it's 10 to the sixth.
It's enormous, which means
that the equilibrium lies very,
very, very, very far over.
And so oftentimes
you'll see if it's
going to strongly dissociate
it, like sodium chloride did,
then you'll sometimes see it
written as just one arrow.
But there's a little
bit going back as well.
That is another
equilibrium constant.
And we will talk about
Ka a little later
and probably pick
up on it next week.
OK, so near full dissociation.
Now, the other thing that
can happen that's important
is water can do both.
Let's see, where should I go?
I'll go back over here.
So water, see that
picture there?
They got it wrong, but it's OK.
They got it right,
because we all get along.
If you want to put H+, fine.
But you know that
it's actually H3O+.
OK, but you can
put H+, no problem.
OK, now there it is.
And you can see that what
water can do is it can do both.
And that turns out to
be extremely important.
So if I take water and
I mix it with water,
ah ha, then you can get a
combination of these ions,
oh, plus a whole bunch of water.
So this would be
like dissociation.
Now, the word for this,
water can turn into either.
It can be basic or acidic.
It can deliver OH- or H3O+.
That's called autoionization,
and it also has a special word.
Water is called
amphoteric, amphoteric.
Now, that means that
the same thing can
be both, both acid or a base.
It can act as either.
So if you take pure water--
so let's see.
If I take pure water
and [GROANS] and I look
at the concentrations
of these, so H3O+,
it's all happening
from the water.
There's nothing in it.
I didn't add anything to it.
It's just pure water, H3O+.
So that means that if
that reaction happens,
it's going to generate
the same number.
So the H3O+ would equal the
concentration of the OH-.
And in pure water,
that is a value
that is equal to 1 times 10
to the minus seventh moles
per liter at 25C, at 25C.
And so now we have yet another.
That's neutral.
You can understand
that that's neutral,
because you have the same--
if an acid is H+ or H3O+ in
solution and a base is OH-,
and I've made the same number,
then the acidity and basicity
are neutralizing one other.
So that's neutral.
And in fact, you can
see that that pH is 7.
Oh, and we can even write the
equilibrium constant for water,
which is going to be those
guys, H3O+ times OH-,
which is equal to 10
to the negative 14th,
because that's the dissociation
reaction for water.
Water plus water goes to
those ions in solution.
We ignore the water,
and then we're
left with this same
thing we've been
doing, 10 to the minus 14th.
Now, that takes us--
those are neutral.
And so speaking
of neutral, that's
where we're going to go next.
And I think what I
want to do now is--
so we're going to go next
into neutralizing things,
so like if you add
an acid to a base
or if you add a base to an acid.
And we already said on Monday,
you get salt and water.
But see, to understand that,
you need a broader definition.
Svante is amazing, but
Svante missed something.
And so we need a different
definition of acids and bases
that's more general.
And that's what we're going
to start with on Monday.
But wait, because this
is a great place for me
to work on my arm.
I got to hit--
OK, we're going to go
all the way up there
and all the way up
there and right there
and right there and, well,
there and there and there.
[YELLING]
Oh, that was excitement.
Let's go back there and there.
Well, OK, and there.
Oh, that was the
same direction there.
And there and there in the
middle and there and there.
Oh, that was there and
there and there and there.
You guys are seeing I
need a stronger arm here.
[GRUNTS] I can't
really get too far.
And [GRUNTS].
Oh, that side is all--
and there and there and there.
And one more, I'm going deep.
Have a great
Thanksgiving, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
See you guys on Monday.